it's been so tough to keep this a secret
from everyone we've been putting all the
pieces together for months and I'm so
relieved you can finally talk about it
when Stefani is teaming up with target
for the first music video ever to be
created on live TV and there's only
taken et behind the scenes today it's
all about making sure the camera angles
are right everyone knows their marks and
we're practicing all of my costume
changes we've been running through all
of the little details and just trying to
make sure that Monday's live experience
is seamless it is such an amazing
opportunity to do like live art you know
I've never done anything like this
before the video is for her new single
make me like you it will shoot live
during Grammys on Monday on CBS bad
stuff happens to everyone right and to
be able to like rise above it and
control it would be like okay I'm gonna
turn something bad into something good
watch this and that's what the record
feels like for me there's not one second
and one moment of this experience that
I'm not grateful for i I'm my mind is
being blown
by this artistic opportunity to share my
music through a live video